steve you're on the air in new york i
was just wondering if you guessed
richard christie if uh he and his wife
regret naming this one if the carson
went
that it shouldn't have to be such a bust
in philadelphia richard real quick any
regrets naming your kid after carson
wins
none at all but i feel bad if we cursed
him but i
no it's a great name they won the super
bowl the year that our son was born so
no it's all good
what you do is you just say you named
your kid after carson daly if carson
wentz goes really bad
we'll start calling him by his middle
name kane
what is the new kid's name going to be
have you picked one out yet carter chuck
christie carter so everybody's going to
be a c
yep ccc yeah what's the ccc thing
uh i don't know just fun fun yeah
yeah you call that fun
i really don't have a good explanation
that's fun i can picture that
conversation hey
let's have fun everyone's ccc
you might as well name him covet he's
born in the diamond
cove and christy i worked at a radio
station wccc was the worst call letters
all right look oh by the way howard
somebody just pointed out i screwed up
our son's name is actually cameron chuck
christie
oh
i said carter we thought about carter
for a while but no it's cameron so he
doesn't even know what the kid's name is
gonna be
you're just like my dad my dad doesn't
know my name either well i mean once
he's born i'll remember
it's either that or coca-cola christie